いやひどい狩り方だなぁ今日は肇社長です
俺も3 usj に行きたいよ usj に行きたいけどさ
遠いんだよだからもう amazon で厨房して買いました
百味ビーンズでございます ufj う
ユニバーサル一つジャパン usj かー usj 言ってる本物の
ゆっくりビーツでございます車趣味ビンズですよ
てが x sa 行ってみたいないったことないんだよねが
くさいこともないんですけども配布
今回はお面じゃゼリービーンズを本当でこう一つるッとする食べてさ
今ままツアー鼻くそじゃまずい
わー
やりたいんだけど俺はそっとねバカみたいなもしないか
俺朝た出土しないかうわぁ凄い
あ今味の汁があったいろんな味があるんだな
話すは知ってパンのかテロは自慢のバラチャンプこういう音
入牢篤人ハナック雑とかさ
もちろそうだろうがたくさんあるわけよ0 no
僕はそんなね研究者ですからこんなの一つ一つを食べておじいおいしい言ってる暇が
あったらさ
研究する理由やだから今日はなこちらのミキサーを使って百味ビーンズを全部入れて一
つにします
混ぜます全部100100種類の味があるかどうもしれないけれども
百味 b'z ってかにあるが100の味はあるんですよ
ここに入れて混ぜてできたものは本当にその
もう100個なぜな1つになっているわけですからさ補正行けます渡部もんですよ
誰もが食べた事ないねもうエクスぺクスもう
aera もうすごいあっ
マッハ
持ってるん
もうすぐに食べたいんだけど
続きます
てるダウンいやあーめっちゃ音でかい負担せベアー
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ r
センターってるッ
あああああああっだけどこれはちょっと熱心でちょっと1マットマルティさせていき
ます
ん
あー早い
ゴーンやばいってこれやばいわよバイバイバイすれば触れててなんかなーなんかもう
このようなものと思えない感じになっちゃいました
はいじゃあ下できました
なんか冷蔵庫で凍らせたらすごい
これ食べれるのか着水が混ざるとこんな感じになります
けろですねけど全然早速食べを取ります
ただこれよっしゃー
マジかどぉすればいい
スポーツとなぁと合わせ1靴と明太子宅地食べればいいじゃんなんかちょっと温めたら
かろうじて動くようになりました
ってこずってやつよねなんと一口てくれればいいんだよちょっと今ぐらいだな
ちょっとこれだけ最初したんでこちらはちょっと冷やしてプチに食べれる温度まで下げ
て食べます
入っていうわけでなんとかたまって温度はいい感じになったら食べてみようと思います
感じで見た目でアウトですねはいでは行きましょう
なんかたーーー
tee